oh this is the story of YouTube stop
subscribed it's a couple of girls and a
couple of dozen guys yeah we all want to
be like them except fret no I don't want
to be like him oh no but this is the
story of the YouTube stop subscribe the
most popular people on the world's
biggest video sites
Fred's just 12 but he really loves Judy
and Nicki he has got multiple
personality Kevin from the stolen sex
when he learns that I didn't even
mention Universal Music Group because as
far as like I'm sorry making I'll just
go eat oh this is story of the YouTube
stop subscribe it's a couple of girls
and a couple of dozen yeah
[Music]
except Fred no I don't want to be like
him but miss story of YouTube stop
subscribed my most popular people on the
world's biggest video site Michele's
where I get my video game news and the
Jonas Brothers gonna wanna make me sing
Buck has superior Sassanian princesses
parodies kick ass oh yeah
and sexy phil has figured out what works
just talk about douche bags and hot
girls this is the story of YouTube's
most subscribed it's a couple of girls
and a couple of dozen guy
we all want to be like them except Fred
no I don't want to be like him oh yeah
but this is the story of YouTube's top
subscribed most popular game play on the
world's biggest video site
I must bubble people other world things
video sigh yeah that's the story of the
YouTube stuff subscribed you may have
noticed that during that song I was
wearing a dftba shirt here it is it's at
the MTV a shirt I could talk to you
through it and I just wanted you to know
that you can get these right now if you
order them quickly because we only made
200 and already like 50 of them have
sold and I haven't even talked about it
yet there it is and you can go get it at
dftba.com right now that is all
oh good song John I'll see you soon